اغلقت صناديق الاقتراح في الكويت مساء
اليوم اغلقت بعد ان ادلى الناخبون
باصواتهم في الانتخابات التشريعيه ويتنافس
في هذه الانتخابات نحو
سبعه مرشحين بينهم ثلاثه عشره امراه في
خمس دوائر انتخابيه
من احدى لجان الفرس في الكويت مدير مكتب
الجزيره سعد السعيدي سعد اذا بدات عمليه
الفرز طلعنا على مجريات هذا اليوم
التصويطي وهل بدات الملامح تتضح
نعم وسيله بالفعل نحن نقف الان في لجنه
رئيسيه حقيقه لجنه فرز رئيسيه هنا تجري
عمليه الفرز منذ اكثر بعد ان اغلقت
الصناديق منذ قرابه ساعتين بدات عمليه
الفرس في هذه اللجنه الرئيسيه الفرعيه كل
هذه
النتائج ستحمل هذه الصناديق بعد ان ينتهي
نشاهد هنا ونريد ان نشاهد هنا
القاضي القاضي اللجنه ومع جميع المندوبين
هنا مندوبين المرشحين الى الان يتوصلون
بعد ان اجريت جميع الاوراق بعد فرزت جميع
الاوراق التي موجوده في كل لجان الفرعيه
الى هذه اللجنه الاصليه الان يبدو ان
انتهت هذه
اللجاء عمليه الفرز في هذا هذه اللجنه
الاصليه ستحمل هذه النتائج من اللجنه
الاصليه الى اللجنه الاصليه الرئيسيه وهي
في مكان اخر ثم يتم تجميع كل هذه الارقام
بعد ذلك سيتم اعلان النتائج وتوقع خلال
الساعتين او الثلاث ساعات القادمه ان يكون
هناك نتائج نهائيه له العمليه يامل
الكويتيون حقيقه ان تنهي او ان ينتهي
ويعود حاله التوافق بين البرلمان الجديد
وكذلك بين الحكومه الجديده التي ستشكل
التي سيعلن غدا استقالتها ثم تتشكل خلال
اسبوعين من الان ستكون هناك جلسه وهو
استحقاق ايضا سيكون هناك جلسه للسلطتين
غالبا ستكون ما بين 22 من هذا الشهر او 23
في هذا التاريخ هذا الشهر حتى يبدا
الالتئام للسلطتين لكن حتى الان هذه
النسبه نسبه الحضور في هذه
الانتخابات حاجه وصلت الى يعني هي غير
رسميه حتى الان لكن وصلت الى 51 بالمئه
كما يبدو في من من مصادر غير رسميه وهذه
النتيجه ايضا خالفت النتيجه الماضيه التي
كانت 63 بالمئه هذا التباين وهذا
النزول الذي يتجاوز 12% وهو رقم كبير
حقيقه خصوصا في ان اليوم يوم اجازه وعطله
يعني للكويتين حتى يساهموا في هذا ما يسمى
بالعرس هنا في الكويت هذه النزول في
النسبه عاده والبعض الى امر مهم وهو عزوف
او هناك عزوف لبعض الناخبين بسبب حاله
التململ وهي عباره عن رساله احتجاج يراد
لها او رساله حجاج صامته اراد من لم يحضر
اليها صناديق الاختراع ان يوصلها الى
هؤلاء او هذا البرلمان بان لم يعد هناك
جدوى من هذه الانتخابات المتكرره تذكر
نتذكر بان هناك حاله ابطال كثيره للمجلس
وحل المجلس حتى ان بعض الكويتين يقول قد
لا نكون نامل لا نكون قد صوتنا الى مجلس
سيتم حله قريبا اشكرك جزيلا
من احدى رجال الفرز في الكويت